here we go
hello everyone welcome to today's live
broadcast precision genomics and
precision medicine for MU oncology my
name is Toby ward and I'm a field
application scientist at personnel is
incorporated and I'll be your moderator
for today's event we are pleased to
bring you this educational web seminar
presented by lab roots and sponsored by
personalis a full solution genomic
sequencing company in menlo park
california for more information we
invite you to please visit personal asst
comm we do have a few important
announcements before we begin this
webcast is designed to be interactive
and we encourage you to ask questions
during the event you can submit your
questions by typing them into the Q&A
box which is located in the lower left
hand put your presentation window and
there's a green Q&A button there I will
queue the questions as they come in and
we will try to answer as many as we can
at the end of the presentation if you
have any technical problems viewing or
hearing this presentation please click
on the support button at the top right
of your presentation window or submit
your problem through the green Q&A
button at the lower left this is an
educational webinar and this offers free
continuing medical education credits
such as pace race CM e or CEU after the
webinar is over please click on the c/e
button located in the bottom left hand
corner of your web page and follow the
process to obtain your credits I'd now
like to introduce today's speaker dr.
Aaron newbern Aaron joined personalis as
a field application scientists in 2013
with over 12 years of research
experience in areas of molecular biology
genetics and biotechnology Aaron's field
applications team at person Ellis has
the responsibility for providing both
pre and post-sales technical support for
the ACE cancer portfolio she completed
her post doctoral training at the
National Institute of Mental Health
where she investigated candidate
susceptibility genes for major
psychiatric illnesses and she received
her PhD from The Ohio State University
and integrated biomedical sciences as a
presidential fellow today Aaron will
discuss precision genomics / and
precision medicine for immuno oncology
the learning objectives for the
presentation are first to review offered
opportunities for precision medicine and
immuno oncology from checkpoint
modulators to adoptive cell therapy
second to understand the key accuracy
challenges in utilizing technologies
like next-generation sequencing for
developing particular immunotherapies
such as personalized cancer backs
and finally to evaluate the current
methods to predict likelihood of a
positive response to immunotherapies and
now I'd like to turn it over to Erin for
her presentation thanks totally for that
introduction and thanks to the audience
for joining us today so before we get
going I'd like to just reiterate the
learning objectives that Toby just
mentioned that will be touching on
during the presentation so we'll be
talking about opportunities for
precision medicine and amino oncology
we'll be discussing some of the current
methods out there to predict response to
immunotherapies so here today I'm going
to be focusing on PDL 1 status tumor
mutational burden and also talk about
neo antigen burden as an example of
current predictors and then we'll be
highlighting some of the challenges in
utilizing technology such as
next-generation sequencing for the
development within the immuno oncology
space so this is a tremendously exciting
time for precision medicine and for
therapy and cancer it really is the
moonshot of our times and so the
national cancer moonshot initiative is
looking to make more therapies available
for patients but also to really improve
upon our ability to prevent cancer and
also to detect it early but precision
medicine is already happening in cancer
in specific areas of treatment so an
example is in targeted therapy
Diagnostics so personalis and other
companies are sequencing tumors
identifying the somatic mutations within
the tumors and then using that
information to guide the choice of
specific targeted therapies and this is
very beneficial for both patients and
physicians and these types of tests are
tests that can be ordered today but
there is a whole other area of cancer
treatment that is really proving to be
very transformational and that is a muta
oncology and immunotherapies that
actually harness and augment our own
immune system's ability to fight cancer
so you may have heard that former
President Jimmy Carter was diagnosed
metastatic melanoma that has spread to
his brain and liver and unfortunately he
was given just just a several months to
live last year however he received one
of these immunotherapies and now is
considered to be disease free and this
has been for a type of cancer that
really in the past has defied really
meaningful treatment and so it's not
surprising that the area of
immunotherapy is really exploding and on
this slide I've categorized
immunotherapies into three main areas
for our presentation so the first is
immune checkpoints and immune modulators
so currently there are a variety of
immune checkpoints being investigated
such as PDL 1 ctla-4 and there are other
very promising candidates out there as
well there's also a next generation of
cancer vaccines as well as adoptive cell
therapies that have been very effective
however the fact remains that there are
still individuals that respond to these
immunotherapy treatments and
unfortunately some that do not and so as
these therapies really continue to
evolve and expand it becomes really
important increasingly important to know
which of these therapies are going to
work for a particular tumor type and
also going to work for an individual
patient so determining which patients
will derive benefit from immunotherapy
is an extremely important clinical
question to really try to spare patients
from ineffective treatment but also to
limit their exposure to these treatment
adverse effects so personalis is
starting to determine how we can develop
precision medicine solutions to guide
immunotherapy so for our talk today I'd
like to focus on two particular examples
so the first example immune checkpoints
and immune modulators and then I'll also
be talking and discussing with you
personalized neyo antigen cancer
vaccines so first let's discuss them you
check point blockade
so tumors are eliminated by our immune
system by active surveillance but
eventually they can actually escape our
immune system and we really didn't know
the molecular mechanisms behind this
until more recently so our immune system
is able to recognize and is ready to
eliminate cancer but it can be held back
by these inhibitory receptors and
ligands so tumors can begin to express
these immune point immune checkpoint
genes and then this creates a way then
for the tumor to evade the immune system
so this is an active area of new drug
development so drugs that interrupt
these immune check points such as anti a
ctla4 or anti PDL one can unleash
anti-tumor immunity and really mediate
cancer regression so shown here on the
screen this is a timeline taken from a
recent review and as you can see here in
this timeline published in Nature
Reviews there have been very exciting
milestones that have been reached in the
generation of these checkpoint drugs and
the responses can be very dramatic and
lead to lasting remission and cancers
that at least traditionally have been
difficult to treat however the objective
response rate still ranges from
approximately ten percent to thirty
percent so the question again is how do
we really predict who is going to
respond to these immune checkpoint
therapies so the the first generation of
attempts and predictive biomarkers for
immunotherapies have resulted in the
single gene expression test so looking
at the expression of a single marker so
here PDL 1 status is being determined
and in this case you can see that if the
test is positive you have a twenty-six
percent chance of responding to this
checkpoint inhibitor drug but what all
you can also see is that if you're
negative you have a ten percent chance
of responding so patients negative for
the spire marker may still respond and
so this really complicates the the issue
of using
a PDL one as an exclusive biomarker
exclusive predictor and so you know
these types of tests are course
predictors at best and relatively
underwhelming so the question becomes
how do we build better predictors and
this is what personalis and others are
working on the modulators of the immune
system and immune response are extremely
complex and go well beyond a single gene
and so this raises the opportunity then
to use more sophisticated broader
genomics as well as informatics methods
to really drive this next generation of
precision medicine solutions and so
there are other you know currently other
ideas out there about better signatures
better predictors to determine the
likelihood of response to these
immunotherapies so they've been studies
showing that perhaps mutational burden
as a signature that can potentially
predict response to these
immunotherapies so shown here on the
screen is a snapshot from a New England
Journal of Medicine article using
aluminum for patients with melanoma and
here this is the kaplan-meier survival
curve showing response of patients on
this anti ctla4 therapy correlated with
a higher mutational burden and you can
see that there on the blue line as
compared to individuals with a lower
number of mutations shown in red and so
there have also been studies showing
that perhaps neo antigen burden may also
be used as a potential predictor of
response to mute immunotherapies and
while tumor mutational burden is the
total number of mutations in the coding
region of the tumor genome a subset of
these mutations may result in neo
antigens sonio antigens these are
somatic mutations in cancer that can
generate non-self peptides and when
properly presented on HLA complex can be
targets for tumor specific t-cell
responses so as an example shown here as
a study published on patients with
non-small
so lung cancer receiving anti pd-1
therapy and they show a higher percent
of progression-free survival in tumors
with higher candidate new antigen burden
as compared to tumors with a lower
candidate neo antigen burden so could
neo antigen burden perhaps then be a
more refined predictor for determining
response to these therapies well there
seems to be limited data so far in the
literature but perhaps that is because
the the neo antigen universe has yet to
be clearly defined so making sure we
include both classes of neo antigens
both class 1 and class 2 as well as
making sure that the assays that we use
in this assessment are accurate in
detection and then also that all variant
types are considered in this assessment
so as we search for better molecular
determinants of response to
immunotherapies you know what genomic
assay or footprint do you need to
determine mutational load or to
determine neo antigen load so for
mutational load determination this year
at the 2016 ASCO meeting the ability to
extrapolate total mutational burden
using a large panel was was really
highlighted and there have been several
papers and studies recently to support
this idea a more recent question out
there is what footprint do you need for
a neo antigen load assessment and this
was a very interesting question that was
raised from this recent study in genome
medicine so using samples from patients
with lung or colon adenocarcinoma for
mutational burden assessment they
demonstrated that a large panel and here
this was a panel of three hundred genes
was highly correlated with the whole
exome sequencing results for mutational
burden assessment however when looking
at the ability then to predict you
antigen load using from those same
samples using whole exome sequencing as
compared to this large panel neo antigen
predictions from this large panel we're
very limited
most diagnostic panels consist of cancer
driver genes and many neo antigens
discovered are outside of the typical
cancer driver genes so how do you get at
these new antigens how do you assess
these so as demonstrated from the the
study on the previous slide the existing
panels are really too limited for new
antigen detection these existing assays
are really narrow as they typically
contain 20 or maybe up to 500 genes but
also oftentimes with detecting these neo
antigens the technology is limited by in
complete coverage of genes so that could
lead to missed potential mutations and
then this can lead to limitations and
accurate predictions of neo antigens so
it personnel is we've developed a
platform for accurately detecting the
antigens so our ace immuno ID is an
example of a platform that is broader
more sophisticated and can really help
power this next generation of precision
medicine in immuno oncology so we've
been very innovative in a number of
different areas the first is that we
created and patented the ACE technology
to achieve clinical grade sequencing and
i'll be talking more about that in the
presentation we've also went beyond the
model of looking at one gene or a few
genes at a time but really try to
broaden out and interrogate all 20,000
plus genes and this also involves
integration of both DNA and RNA together
and that feeds into the algorithms that
we put together for neo antigen
detection and at the point here really
is that the ACM you know ID platform
allows the beginning of the
determination of metrics like neo
antigen burden or other biomarkers that
could eventually correlate with
immunotherapy response and serve as this
next generation of precision Diagnostics
so developing the technology and
precision medicine is really just the
start so validation and
regulatory issues are key if you're
going to really use these tests at the
bench side bedside so strong analytical
validation is required but this is
oftentimes challenging and cancer
because there's a lack of existing gold
standards or metrics to really assess
performance so our feelings as a company
at personalis are that we need to move
away from this this wild-west of
genomics and spend really time doing a
very robust analytical validation and
this is very critical so some of the
personnel is scientific founders
co-author this article pictured here on
the screen with individuals from the FDA
that really laid out a roadmap of
regulatory or considerations for how to
regulate within this space so at
personalis we've recognized the need for
clinical grade sequencing and
informatics as well to support
diagnostic use and so in the next set of
slides I'd like to speak to how we've
addressed this need so first let's look
at sequencing assays so one of the
biggest challenges in standard whole
exome sequencing assays are the gaps and
inconsistencies and the coverage so for
example this is a sequencing plot shown
here on your screen of the SDK 11 gene
using standard exome sequencing so this
is the agilent clinical research XOM
assay that was used and the plot shows
all the exons concatenated together and
the read depth is shown here on your
y-axis and so as you notice although
this gene is sequence to add a high
depth and so in this case we're looking
at an average of greater than 100 x
coverage it still fails to cover whole
exonic regions and you can see that
there in the red brackets as shown and
so variants that reside in these regions
would be completely missed so we've
recognized these issues with the
standard exome and built the ACE exome
design that works by taking the standard
X
zome shown here in blue on the schematic
and adding supplemental coverage in
green for those problematic areas in the
genome that are difficult to cover so
these are combined then in an effort to
maximize genomic content and really
provide uniformity and coverage to
increase confidence in calling variants
also not only do we target exonic
content but we've also augmented
coverage of biomedical important regions
outside the exon such as regulatory
regions energetic or intronic areas so
if i go back to to STK 11 this is a nice
visual of the quality of data that you
would receive from an enhanced exome
approach such as ours so we provide you
with the blue plus the green
supplemental coverage and this results
in more accurate more uniform coverage
across this critical gene and so and and
with our ace augmentation we go beyond
the cancer driver genes and finish over
8,000 bio medically important genes or
random somatic mutations can occur and
here are some more sequencing plots just
to show you a visual of a variety of
genes with gaps inconsistencies and
coverage that are very nicely filled in
by the ACE technology and this is
particularly important for amino
oncology studies and our augmented exome
approach that we use was recently
highlighted in nature reviews genetics
and an article titled towards precision
medicine so the author mentions the the
challenges with standard XM assays as
coverage of certain areas can can be
very limited like gc-rich regions and
they show a gene here that is poorly
covered with a standard eczema say so
this is a critical gene k CN h to a
potassium channel gene that is
associated with long and short QT
syndrome and with an augmented approach
such as ours we have more uniformity
across this critical gene than the
standard assays
likewise accurate identification of the
express somatic variants using whole
exome sequencing is critical as you are
defining your genomic solutions for
precision medicine in many of these
cancer studies formalin-fixed
paraffin-embedded samples are the
materials available for analysis and at
least in the past these sample types
have been quite challenging for genomic
and most definitely for transcriptomic
studies so typical enrichment methods
such as poly a rye boda pletion have
limitations such as inconsistent removal
of these ribosomal RNA reads or just the
inability to work with these more
degraded sample types so methods such as
our exome capture transcriptome protocol
the the ACE cancer transcriptome allows
you to overcome these limitations so
again RNA seek is quite critical for neo
antigen detection as you really want to
determine if these variants are indeed
expressed variants so using an exome
capture transcriptome protocol and here
are four different cancer genes shown on
the screen this enables more sensitive
variant detection so in blue you can see
the transcriptome coverage using a
standard RNA seek methodology whereas
using an optimized exome capture
transcriptome protocol the blue plus the
green provides more sequencing coverage
across these critical cancer genes for
increased sensitivity for somatic
variant detection so next I'd also like
to further highlight that strong
analytical validation of the assays and
the informatics for these precision
medicine solutions is critical I want to
share just a few slides on the approach
we use for analytical validation of our
enhanced exome for use in neo antigen
detection so in these next set of slides
I'll be focusing on our approach for our
ace cancer XO mass a but we also have
completed a validation of our
transcriptome as well
so as an example of this process I'm
going to walk through how we assess
analytical sensitivity for small
variance so the positive percent
agreement and the positive predictive
value were computed over a range of
minor allele frequencies and one of the
major challenges facing the industry
when you're performing these types of
analytical validations is the lack of an
established gold standard or reference
samples that can be used as as a ground
truth so we developed a validation
approach where we used well
characterized cancer cell lines to
generate these reference samples that
could represent variant types and so in
our study we used a set of gold
standards and we refer to our gold set
as a set of cosmic verified events so
this means that they were detected in
the cosmic cell line project and also
verified by two other sources so cancer
cell line encyclopedia the NCI 60 or
then confirmed by staying or sequencing
so in total here across the 11 cell
lines that we used for our X own
validation the gold set that we defined
here looked at 875 snv's and 19 in dells
and so in our approach here the 11
specific cancer cell lines also had the
corresponding match normal cell lines
available so we sequence these 11 pairs
then ran our somatic tumor normal
pipeline and then we compared these
variant results to the gold set of
standards so we also looked at our
limits of detection of these small
variance using three pairs of tumor and
normal cell lines we created Aleutians
to represent a five percent up to an 80%
tumor purity as you see here on the
screen so for example we took five
percent of the tumor cell line mix that
with ninety-five percent of the normal
cell line to simulate a five percent
tumor purity and so on here up to an
eighty percent tumor purity and so I've
shared here just a brief overview of our
approach for our ex home and as I
mentioned we've completed the analytical
validation of our transcriptome as well
and we feel that it's critical very
important to measure the performance of
these assays that are being used and so
from that plan we are very pleased to
share these final results for the small
variance so our overall analytical
sensitivity for snv's and in dells using
our ace cancer exim is ninety-eight
percent and ninety-five percent
respectively and then what we've done
here on the screen in the the second
table is show the the PPA in the ppv and
it specifically parsed out here for the
snv's and the in dell results as well as
the value for the for the overall for
small variance so you can see this at a
ten percent minor allele frequency as
well as at a twenty percent minor allele
frequency and as you can see here our
results are quite good so now that you
have accurate clinical grade
comprehensive sequencing data how then
do you identify and predict potential
neo antigens so this is a workflow here
for our process to enable accurate
candidate new antigen detection so it
starts here by taking a cancer sample
and a match normal sample from the
patient we sequence that with our
enhanced ace cancer exome that I just
described to you and this sequencing
data is then analyzed through our
somatic analysis pipeline to generate
the set of all somatic variants we then
use RNA derived from those tumor samples
to perform our enhanced whole
transcriptome sequencing so somatic
variants are then called in the RNA as
well and then can be cross-referenced
with the somatic variants called in the
DNA and this then allows the ability to
look at the set of all somatic variants
that are actually expressed and
therefore could be potential neo antigen
candidates and we believe that that the
assays that are being used in this
process can rule
make a difference and here's an example
of a candidate neo antigen identified in
a patient sample so you can see the
coverage above hear of this Bluegreen
palat of the DNA and RNA coverage for
this variant so this was a missense
mutation in the RPS to gene and the red
line there shows you exactly where this
this candidate new antigen resides and
it's quite possible that this variant
would have been undetected by a standard
assay but with an Augmented exome
approach such as ours it provides
greater sensitivity to detect these
candidate neo antigens and so one of the
very exciting pieces in this space is
the ability to further predict neo
antigens through deeper bioinformatics
analysis so at personalis we're
currently developing a neo antigen
prediction pipeline and for us it starts
by imputing into our this this algorithm
our pipeline our high-quality data so
utilizing our optimized exone to
sequence the the tumor and a match
normal we perform epitope prediction
then we also perform in silico HLA
typing to determine MHC binding
capabilities and then in parallel using
our optimized ace transcriptome we use
the gene expression the variant
expression information to determine
similarity to known antigens as well as
similarity to self so this then all
these pieces then will be used to rank
and report out candidate neo antigens
and so so far we've spoken about neo
antigens in the context of precision
medicine for checkpoint blockade
therapies so this is the idea of using
new antigen burden as a predictive
signature however there is another
entire application of neo antigens which
is in creating truly personalized cancer
vaccines so for personalized cancer
vaccine development you can identify the
neo antigen and then create a synthetic
vaccine that is personalized for this
particular
tumor and then provide that to the
patient and oftentimes this vaccine is
provided in combination with these
checkpoint blockade therapies as well as
can be provided with targeted therapies
or chemotherapies as well and so here
you have a tumor specific personalized
cancer vaccine created for this
individual patient so in summary as we
conclude our presentation and open up
for some Q&A personalis and other
companies are already working on
precision diagnostics for for cancer and
targeted therapies but there is a new
area immunotherapy that is incredibly
exciting and transformational and there
are tremendous opportunities for
precision medicine in that realm as well
and so as a company we're working on
solutions to to help predict who will
respond to checkpoint blockade therapies
and also working on solutions that will
drive the development of personalized
cancer vaccines and as we look to the
future it starts by making sure that the
assays as well as the informatics
involved in this process are of the
highest quality and highest accuracy so
if you'd like to learn more about the
solutions we've designed within our
portfolio please visit our virtual booth
at the lab route lab roots conference
today and you can also message us at
info at personalis com thanks Aaron
thank you for that informative
presentation before we get started on
the Q&A session I'd like to remind our
audience how to submit their questions
you can submit your questions by typing
them into the Q&A box which is found at
the lower left-hand of your presentation
window at the green Q&A button will try
to answer as many questions as we can
our first question that we already
received is do you require a match
normal sample for your processes and if
so what types of tissues do you accept
as a match normal okay yeah so in the
new antigen pipeline that I that I
showed you you saw that we do take both
the tumor as well as the match normal in
this process
and this really increases the
specificity of the the somatic analysis
however you know depending on your
project depending on your application we
can work with you on that our
bioinformatics capabilities are very
versatile we also have a pipeline that's
configured to work when when you don't
have that match normal available so in
that case we use a proxy normal and a
database as well as some bioinformatic
filters to help compensate when
unfortunately that that match normal
might not be available great thank you
oh and I think you also asked that also
what's up yeah what types of tissues you
accept yeah so we we accept blood as the
match normal we can also take normal
adjacent tissue as well right thank you
the second question that we got was what
are the typical deliverables that you
provide back after a sequencing project
yeah and again we can you know work with
you and this can in talk with you
specifically about what you may require
but we do have very comprehensive
deliverables we give you you know the
raw data the the fast cue files the
alignment files the variant call files
as well as the full somatic pipeline we
have a very nice sequencing QC report
that we can deliver and then also for
for RNA we do provide gene expression
values as well as gene fusion
information so we have a list of you
know standard deliverables however we
can also work and Taylor and customized
output depending on what your needs
might be so you know I'd encourage folks
to visit our booth today or to message
us and we can talk to you about some
specific output requirements and needs
that you might have great a related
question is what are the standard
turnaround times for the essays that
you've offered today okay yeah and and
again this this can often times it
depends on on the project and the
application at hand we do for for
clinical trials can offer a very
expedited turn around time of 14
calendar days if needed for more
standard products such as if it's a
research study we typically have about a
42
26 week turnaround time but again these
can be based on on your needs as well
okay here's a technical question for
your amino oncology applications do you
have a recommended depth of sequencing
that you think is sufficient to drive
these projects yeah so in the validation
that I presented here the approach we
use for for the validation this
validation was specifically geared for
for neo antigen detection and in this
case we are typically sequencing the
tumor to a you know 200 x type coverage
and pairing that with about a hundred x
or so of the match normal sample and so
for certain applications of course a
higher depth like vaccine development
may be required but we also offer a
variety of different sequencing outputs
and end depths depending again upon the
study need ok we have time for one last
question and that question is do you
offer other essays besides this whole
exome and whole transcriptome
configuration yeah so there wasn't time
today but we do it so we offer our
enhanced XM and transcriptome which
gives you as you can see very broad
profiling and we've optimized for
accuracy within that assay and some of
obviously definite applications for
immuno oncology however we also have a
enhanced cancer panel for both DNA and
RNA it's currently the most
comprehensive cancer panel out there on
the market it's 1,400 cancer genes and
we do both DNA and RNA of that panel
within the design of that panel we've
we've really tried to make sure that we
include you know very critical genes and
as well as include very critical cancer
pathway analysis and so this panel has a
definitely suited for for targeted
therapy applications as well as am you
know oncology application so today we
were talking about the ability of a
panel to extrapolate mutational burden
assessment and this would be possible
with our panel all right I'd like to
once again thank dr. Newbern for her
presentation would you like to make any
final comments thanks for for everybody
for for joining us today and
please check out our booth today at the
the virtual conference okay I would also
like to thank our sponsor personnel is
incorporated for making today's
educational webcast possible please
visit personnel scom for more
information about our company and our
capabilities as a reminder today's
webcast will be available for on-demand
viewing for six months from the live
date until April 2017 you should receive
an email from lab roots alerting you win
this webcast will be available for
replay and we do invite you to forward
that announcement to your colleagues who
may have missed today's live event see
you next time goodbye